they they took me in on on state charges
of criminal simulation over 60 000
um
and you know i think it took like two
and a half three months for the the feds
to finally compile all their evidence
because they went got a warrant to go
through the computer
you know i mean get all the evidence
they needed and then they served me an
indictment about two and a half three
months later
wow
so you were sitting in like uh just like
a state
prison
before that at first there was just knox
county james was in a jail just like the
local jail yeah for months and then the
when the feds got involved
then what happened like did what changed
what's the once the fbi got involved
well it's it's a secret service oh it's
a secret service they handle a lot of
forgotten
handle the money [ __ ] right um but yeah
basically they took me to court one day
and my public defender was like you know
they're they're dropping their charges
on you
but because i knew the state or the feds
were going to pick them up you know i
mean if the state drops them it's
so basically they you know went to court
the state dropped all charges
and then they walked me across the
street to the federal marshall building
and they served me in the indictment for
the conspiracy at first it was a five
count indictment
for uh let's see conspiracy to
counterfeit u.s obligations
uh like a couple counts of uttering
u.s obligations
um
and i think it was like sale and
manufacturer of counterfeit u.s
obligations
so that you know eventually i pled to
just one count of the conspiracy to
counterfeit cause they don't they don't
run you know concurrent anyway so they
basically just give you the biggest
charge and right you know drop the other
ones but
so
what did they charge you with they
charged you they gave you one charge and
how long did they sentence you
well for
originally uh in the feds it's like a
it's a range you know what i mean you
get like you know
12 to 18 months or you know so it's like
um originally i was looking at it was
like three years about give or take
so
they they came to me with this deal and
said
if you
can
you know plead guilty
and
show us how you made these bills
make a make a video to train future
agents um
you know basically
just explain all the evidence what it
was how i learned about it you know all
that
and and make a training video for future
secret service agents
then they would
not charge my wife
and
keep the restitution amount under a
hundred thousand dollars
because that's an enhancement so once
once it was once you make more than a
hundred thousand dollars you get more
time you know i mean it's like an
enhancement in the feds so
they basically said they were like at
this point we found 380 000
in knoxville we're still finding about
10 grand a week coming in through the
bank so they were like if you plead
guilty now we'll keep it at under 100
um and not charge your wife so
basically i made like a a video they
flew a film crew down to knoxville and
like filmed me making bills
really in the secret service
headquarters
really yeah what was that like so you
were imprisoned
while you had to film this right like
you were still doing your time no no
this was they actually well they let me
out on pre-trial release for uh some
months before i was sentenced okay and
that's when i did all that so the secret
service flew a film crew down to your
house to the secret service headquarters
headquarters knoxville you met him there
yeah
did you like how did you did they did
you have to give them like a list of
equipment and [ __ ] or like how did that
work um
basically they just went through and
asked me like exactly
you know what certain chemicals were why
i had certain things what did i you know
use them for how did i find out
that i could use them for you know what
i mean
um because i had i would always
experiment with stuff trying to make the
bills better you know what i mean so
i had like the
that that makeup right that i made the
color shifting pigment out of
there was one kind that was the best
but i had like a bunch of other ones
because i'd experiment
and i was uh
working on doing the new blue notes as
well and that's got a different color
shift
so i had stuff to match that color
shifting a certain type of nail polish
mixed in with a
color shifting pigment i got online if
you mix them together it makes a perfect
copper to gold like on the new hundreds
so there was stuff like that and uh
like i found a uh it's like a fine tip
ballpoint glue pen
so it it it's like a regular bic pen
except it pushes out glue instead of ink
so like some people to test if a bill is
real they'll scratch the shirt with what
they say which means you feel the
texture
you know you kind of run your fingernail
along his his t-shirt on the portrait of
the president right to feel the texture
so i ran across a couple cashiers that
would do that
um
so i had this little glue pen that i'd
draw little lines on real quick to give
this
rigid texture on the shirt just weird
like little things like that that
they've never the secret service hasn't
seen before or or was wondering why i
had you know this these pens or this you
know this or that basically yeah
and you know i basically took my my
computer you know printed a a couple
bills
glued them sprayed the lacquer you know
explained what i was doing
and uh you know they counted that as as
cooperation to to give me
from three years it got knocked down to
10 months wow
10 months
[Music]
it seems like i mean obviously it's a
long [ __ ] time but it doesn't it
doesn't seem like that long for all the
[ __ ] that you were doing um i mean no
it's
it was definitely a blessing you know
because i there was drug dealers that i
met
multiple ones that i would they'd find
out the bills were fake
after i was ripping them off or whatever
and i i'd offered to sell them sell them
the bills and they'd be like no i don't
want to [ __ ] with that you know i mean
that's serious [ __ ] and it's like
there are people you know trafficking
kilos of heroin with guns on them and
stuff and they're they're worried about
kind of bills you know right you weren't
doing anything violent so no yeah so i
mean the time for i mean it's it's a
white-collar crime so most most
white-collar crimes don't look at
nearly as much time as drugs and guns
they don't they don't like drugs and
guns so how long did the process take
for you to film that training video for
the secret service
uh it was probably like two two hours
two hours how many bills did you make
for them oh just two just two
i didn't know at the time my lawyer was
pregnant at the time i felt bad after
the fact because i was showing him
everything and then i take this lacquer
spray can
and i started spraying it and she was
like oh i gotta leave the room and like
ran out and i didn't think i was like oh
i'm sorry it smells you know i mean but
later i found out that she was pregnant
so i feel bad about that you know i mean
but
but she is all good with it oh my god
that's so wild so what what uh so you
only ended 10 months what was the 10
months like
was it a low low security yeah well it
was it was a
administrative
facility which is like a camp
no it wasn't a camp it was a it's a low
security basically there's camps lows
you know
medium and highs
but uh
i went uh
i was in i got sentenced then i had to
sit in knox county jail for you know a
couple weeks and then they send me to
blount county jail which is the federal
holding facility for east tennessee sat
there for like a month
then they shipped me to
london kentucky
laurel county is like another federal
holding facility it's just kind of a
holdover until they get you to the
compound
um and then they sent me to fmc
lexington
which is like i said it's an
administrative low so it houses low
medium and highs
but it's essentially a low low security
um
and you know
it wasn't bad shot some pool you know
worked out a little bit
really yeah what kind of guys did you
meet in there
matt cox type people
no not
i was i was one of the few there was a
couple guys that uh
did what one dude was doing credit card
fraud i think okay uh he was like he
owned a company and was like basically
like
overcharging
people who you know
gave him this credit card like bought a
product from him and then he'd like
overcharge them and then refund them and
he had some kind of scammed where he
made it made out on top
i